(playful music)
(clears throat)
(chuckles wryly)
(metal squeaking)
(clears throat)
- So!
- So.
- So you're from Chicago.
- Yep.
- So what was that like?
- It was fine.
- You know I spent a summer in Chicago.
- Oh really?
- So, when I was there
I worked at a comic shop
and one day this guy
came in and he was buying
a bunch of t-shirts
and they were all Firefly t-shirts.
So of course I asked him,
I was like hey, do you like
the show Firefly or something?
And he was like, yeah I'm a big fan.
And so, I'm ringing him up at the register
and guess who walks in?
None other than Nathan Fillion.
(laughs) Right?
The whole time I was actually helping
the brother of Nathan Fillion.
(laughs sheepishly)
- That's so funny.
So I'm really into this
season of Homeland.
Do you watch?
- Nope.
Well I don't get Showtime.
I used to, but then
the only show I watched
was Ray Donovan.
So then I found out that it was cheaper
to actually buy each episode
a la carte on Amazon.
And so then I got an Apple TV
and through the Amazon app I'm able
to just purchase each episode
and it's, it works that way.
- My ex, he loves Ray Donovan, ugh.
He kinda looks like Liev Schreiber.
- Oh wow, he must be super handsome.
- Yeah.
- Cool.
So do you want another drink?
- Oh no, no I'm good, thank you.
- Oh okay.
- So um, you know I
should probably get going.
I have a busy day tomorrow.
- Oh okay.
Well, let me walk you to your car.
- Oh I'm just parked right outside.
- Oh.
- Okay, you know what?
It was a pleasure meeting you.
Thank you so much Edgar.
- It's Elliot, actually.
- What?
- Nevermind.
We should do this again some time.
How 'bout next week?
- Maybe, just go ahead and text me.
- Okay.
- [Gir] Okay, bye.
- Cool.
Okay.
- [Girl] Okay, bye.
- So how'd it go?
- Awesome. (laughs)
Best date I've ever had.
She definitely likes me.
Yeah.
- [Barkeep] Yeah, I don't think she does.
- Yeah, she had this look in her eyes.
You know, it was just like (growls).
- [Barkeep] Yeah, I saw that look.
- I wanna jump your bones.
(both laugh)
Yeah.
- [Barkeep] Yeah.
- Yeah you know that look?
- [Barkeep] Yeah, I do.
- You ever seen that?
You probably haven't seen that before.
- How's your Blue Balls?
- Really, really blue.
- I mean the drink.
- Oh yeah, can I have another?
- Sure.